Hey team it’s Charlie and Walking Dead just
released a new trailer for season 5 so this
will be a breakdown of that along with some
mailbag.
I haven’t done a Q&A in a while and I still
want to do my Michonne video as a separate
thing.
So that’s still coming.
More new stuff happening this week so annoucements
at the end
of the video.
Here we go, just a reminder spoilers for everything
through season 4.
I’ll wait just a sec...okay, here we go:
Starting off with fire walkers patrolling
Terminus.
It’s hard to tell just from this clip but
most of the time trailers like this only include
bits from the first couple of episodes.
So this kind of implies Walkers will enter
terminus somehow.
I hope you don’t have epilepsy, because
this next montage will totally give you a
siezure.
It just tells more of the shitstorm that goes
down at Terminus.
It’s all footage from the previous trailers,
but I think Gareth’s voice over is a clue.
It’s not over.
I think the montage tells the story of the
destruction of Terminus.
At some point, Rick and the Survivors barrell
out of the Traincar like we saw in the first
trailer.
Then get their hands on some guns and manage
to blow a giant chunk out of Terminus and
let some walkers in.
But that’s not the end of it.
Gareth is seen with them in the trailer in
later scenes, so he’s traveling with them
for some reason.
Possibly because of Eugene’s cure, which
may or may not be fake.
If you’ve read the comics just use spoiler
tags when talking about that.
Carol and Tyreese were seen outside Terminus
with Judith so at some point they arrive at
Terminus before everything goes crazy.
And here we see Carol asking where people
are holding this giant rifle.
That looks like it’s at Terminus at night.
So she seems like a big part of their escape
plan.
I’d be surprised if all these scenes are
only from the first episode.
But it’s totally possible this big explosion
and these fire walkers happen at the climax.
It would be a pretty badass way to open a
season that’s being teased as a return to
crazy action for the show.
Rick keeps giving speeches in this church
about not trusting ‘them’, until we meet
a new group of people I’m going to assume
he’s talking about people from Terminus.
It’s also possible he could be talking about
Abraham, Eugene, Rosita and Tara.
We do see Father Gabriel’s church in the
clips from the outside.
That’s in the woods somewhere, not inside
Terminus.
No word on which episode Seth Gilliam will
debut in, I’m expecting the first episode
to mostly be localized around Terminus.
There was a recent season 5 synopsis that
posted to Fox International’s website that
read
Season 5 is a story that weaves the true motives
of the people of Terminus with the hopeful
prospect of a cure in Washington, D.C., the
fate of the group's lost comrades, as well
as new locales, new conflicts, and new obstacles
in keeping the group together and staying
alive.
Stories will break apart and intersect.
The characters will find love and hate.
Peace and conflict.
Contentment and terror.
And, in the quest to find a permanent, safe
place to call home, one question will haunt
them...
After all they've seen, all they've done,
all they've sacrificed, lost, and held onto
no matter what the cost...
Who do they become?
So what does all that mean?
I think we’ve all come to the conclusion
that the Terminus people are just analogs
of The Hunters in the comics, so that’s
what I think the “True Motives” line is
all about.
Washington DC is one of the next big locations
in the story.
They aren’t anywhere close to that, Terminus
is in Macon, Georgia.
So sometime during this season they’ll hit
the road.
No idea if they’ll get there before Season
6.
They really didn’t travel that far from
the Prison in season 4.
The line about Lost comrades sounds like Beth,
we know her story is going to take place away
from the survivors at this weird creepy hospital
for at least half the season.
New Locales includes Father Gabriel’s Church
here.
New obstacles just sounds like them running
into crazies on the way to Washington DC.
When they talk about the stories breaking
apart and intersecting I’m wondering if
some of them might split up after they escape
Terminus.
Like Abraham and a group try to head to Washington
DC and a couple others go in a different direction
to try and find Beth.
I’ll say one of my favorite new things from
the trailer is Carol here in full poncho gear
and warpaint.
You should know that when you wear the poncho
you get a 60% bonus to your crit rating.
Let me know what your favorite moment was
and do you think Carol rescues everyone from
Terminus in that first episode?
While you guys think about that here’s a
few mailbag questions:
Question 1 - Mohammed Udin asks when does
season 5 start?
Good question, October 12th at 9PM eastern
time for people in the US or if you stream
it.
If you watch it on TV in the UK or internationally
I think there’s a couple week delay in the
episodes airing.
Like you get episodes a couple weeks after
we get episodes.
Someone from the UK please confirm in the
comments.
It’s the same drill as Season 4 episodes.
Question 2 - Jason Pineda asks Do you think
someone from the group will die in Terminus?
No, but I do think one of the lesser characters
will die this season.
I don’t think everyone will make it to Washington
DC.
Question 3 - Nico Mark asks could the building
Beth is in be connected to Terminus, is it
nearby?
I think she’s somewhere completely different,
I don’t think her story will intersect with
the other survivors till the second half of
the season next spring.
Question 4 - Umesh asks do you think they
show too much footage in the trailer?
All trailers for everything basically tell
you the whole story of the season, the episode,
the movie.
I spend most of my time trying analyze things
for discussion.
So my enjoyment of things doesn’t really
depend on big surprises in the plot.
I get more excited about watching the actors
act when they do a good job, but Walking Dead
is based on a comic that is way ahead of the
plot.
It’s the same drill with Game of Thrones.
Question 5 - Lucy asks how do you think Rick
will react to Tara?
I think he’ll just be wary of a new person
just like he’s wary of Abraham, Eugene and
Rosita.
Generally he looks like he’s not going to
trust anyone new this year.
So couple of important announcements, my Michonne
video will probably post on Sunday.
Tonight is Agents of SHIELD Season 2.
I’ll be posting my review after the episode,
but I already did a Preview video to help
you guys get ready, so click here to check
that out.
It’s going to be awesome.
Lucy Lawless is on this year.
And click here for my top 5 Badass Rick Grimes
moments.
Thanks for watching, everybody high five and
we’ll meet up later tonight for SHIELD.